now last night Florida Republican
Congressman Byron Donald sparred with
far left lunatic over at msdnc or NBC
host Joy Reed as and showed us just why
he's such a rising star on the
Republican Party watch this
so do you not believe that the idea was
to make a diversity statement by
nominating it well actually first that
was not the idea because I was in a room
when the decision was made by people who
chose to nominate me that never came and
you you're still not explained how how
your profit you've never been in
leadership are you gonna let me answer
your questions
number two now let's go back the reality
is is that a lot of members actually do
believe in my ability to lead they do am
I to be despised from my youth because
I've served one term my members know
that I have the ability to engage all
the members through the conference but
it's even bigger than that listen we
were at an impasse last week in our in
our speakership elections we got that
done Kevin McCarthy is now Speaker of
the House on voting laws you voted you
once art you defend voting laws that
said getting rid of ballot harvesting is
a good thing that we did so you've
defended the Florida voting laws
um and you've actually falls in the
country the Florida voting election laws
are the best election laws in the
country and U.S Arizona go as California
go ask New York we do it the best okay
all right
now of course Joy Reid has a history of
these types of smeared tactics does does
NBC stand by this here's another small
sample take a look
I think even though we intellectually
understand what America is at its base
right that there is a great amount of
racism anti-blackness anti-wokeness so
for so many reasons being a freeloader
and a selfish and disrespectful one and
for misappropriating black vernacular
for misogynistic purposes Elon Musk is
the absolute worst the coverage of
Ukraine has revealed a pretty radical
disparity in how human ukrainians look
and feel to Western media compared to
their Browner and Blacker counterparts
but if somehow they managed to stumble
into the Supreme Court do any of you
guys trust Uncle Clarence and Amy Coney
Barrett and those guys to actually
follow the letter of the law Tim Scott
standing there to provide the patina of
diversity over that uh round of words
that uh basket full of words
now sadly the politics of personal
destruction is nothing new from the left
as Congressman Donald's wife Erica is
now shining a light on the attacks that
they both receive from unhinged liberal
agitators tweeting quote Byron and I
have been together for 23 plus years and
the most racist attacks we experience
are always from the left they can't
accept that a free thinking black man
achieved success on his own merits and
they sure as heck can't stand that he's
married to me try harder haters here
with reaction Congressman Byron Donalds
and his wife Erica Eric I think you need
to join him in Congress in the senate in
politics because I loved your Tweet and
you're right I've gotten to know your
husband and he's a natural-born leader a
great story in terms of personal success
have you gotten a lot of reaction to
that Erica
definitely more reaction than I expected
Sean and I really appreciate you having
me on but the truth is just what you
said my husband is a natural-born leader
he is the future of the Republican Party
his colleagues in Congress know it his
colleagues from the Florida house know
it people who worked with him in his
career in finance know it I certainly
know it and my boys do it's unfortunate
that those on the other side tried to
they're the ones trying to tokenize him
and say that the only reason he's
successful is because of the color of
his skin or because of who his wife is
and the color of my skin we all know
that that's not true and he has achieved
his success by hard work Merit and
intelligence and I'm so proud of him uh
and you should be I mean I've gotten to
know know you congressman and uh I I
find it an honor I love your life story
but you look at Joy Reid I was surprised
you went on her show she used the term
Uncle Clarence about Clarence Thomas she
once suggested the GOP as hatred for
Biden because he was the vice president
to a black president she once said
education the issue is code for white
parents who don't want race taught in
schools maybe she forgot Joe Biden
partnered with a former klansman to stop
integration of public schools he didn't
want schools to be a racial jungle she
also said people on the right would
trade all the tax cuts for the ability
to openly say the n-word
where does she get this from and what's
your reaction to NBC
well I mean look I don't really pay much
attention to what Joy says I think going
on the show was more about bringing the
ideas of conservatism to all voters
something I told my voters back in
Southwest Florida I was going to do and
you know I have no problem doing those
interviews because it's important that
all Americans hear the ideas that
conservatives pushing that we believe in
because it's been the thing that's made
America the beacon of light across the
world so I'm not afraid of the of the of
the tough talk or the battles because
that's what's necessary for
republicanism and conservatism more
importantly to succeed in these United
States Erica how do you feel now that
your husband has been in Congress and is
in Congress has now emerged as a leader
the attack seemed to escalate you okay
with all that
you know we have thick skin Sean you
might know I served on the school board
in our local County and that's
to get attacked you might be
investigated as a domestic terrorist
S I definitely am one of those active
parents Byron and I have been involved
in this fight for over 10 years now
members of the Tea Party Movement
conservatives in our community we are no
stranger to the battle against the left
and we're not afraid of them and it
takes leaders like Byron to go on MSNBC
and CNN and battle them with ideas with
policies with facts and let the world
know that we are not afraid to come with
the receipts and show the America the
truth about their policies and the
impact of them I personally gave up on
the mall after I went on The View with
Rosie O'Donnell that was it for me a
total waste of my time uh anyway
Congressman thanks for being with us uh
Erica great to have you congratulations
23 years both of you we appreciate your
time